[Applaudissements]
nous avons des indications quelque chose
ensuite nous donner son concert c'est
étrange je m'inquiéte mans alors que
l'apparence est d'abord un immense
progrès démocratique qui est d'ailleurs
inventé ici en france plus ou moins
c'était passionnant
le designer événement au xviiie siècle
mon amie française est marrante et la
transparence ou en exigeant des bois
qu'il cesse de servir une éloge secret
pour signer le despotisme vaincu les
pouvoirs pour protéger les parallèlement
à ça d'ailleurs en maintenant la map et
la transparence des pouvoirs on a marqué
l'arrivée l'idée qu'il existe des
citoyens la mer noire donc c'était un
problème rcc et fussent décennies un
génie c'est impossible
on a essayé d'avoir de plus en plus des
pouvoirs responsable et qui rendait des
comptes aux citoyens
alors en quoi est-ce que c'est
inquiétant ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que quelque chose est en train de
changer de muter dans la transparence
sous l'effet de la rencontre d'un côté
d'une idéologie et d'autre part d'une
technologie l'idéologie elle nous vient
des états unis
elle puise ses racines en dation de ce
pays par des puritains quand j'utilise
ce terme il n'était pas négatif
historiquement il n'était pas mais
disons qu'il y avait une vision pure de
la religion et qui considérait eux que
la transparence et le fait d'être nu
devant
et devant ses semblables pour chacun
d'entre nous et ça se traduit par une
formule qui a utilisé encore récemment
un patron de google
si vous n'avez rien à vous reprocher
alors vous n'avez rien à cacher formule
qui est assez inquiétante pour nous
européens nous on considère qu'on a le
droit à une vie privée
on peut avoir des relations amoureuses
amical sentimentale sexuelle avoir des
goûts avoir une vie sociale avoir des
préférences qui n'ont rien de coupables
mais qu' on n'est pas obligé de mettre
sur la place publique
eh bien ça s'est heurté frontalement par
l'idée que tout doit être sur la place
publique
ça c'est l'idéologie et elle entre en
résonance avec quelque chose que vous
connaissez tous qui est la technologie
numérique la technologie numérique
produit une capacité de l'intrusion et
d'invasions dans notre vie à partir de
ce qu'on appelle les données
personnelles qui est sans exemple dans
notre histoire à partir de notre
fréquentation des moteurs de recherche
des sites fonction par exemple ce que je
préside à travers notre utilisation des
réseaux sociaux à travers les sites de
e-commerce nous laissons toute une série
de traces qui regroupait traiter avec
des puissances de calcul phénoménale et
des outils qu'on appelle les algorithmes
et qui sont extrêmement puissants sea
qui permettent de cerner notre vie dans
des proportions dont on n'avait pas idée
jusqu'à lors réponse est nécessairement
à quel point nous participons les
utilisateurs de facebook laisse en
moyenne 98 informations sur leur vie
lorsqu'ils utilisent facebook moyenne et
donc facebook c'est ce que nous mangeons
qui nous voyons quel statut matrimonial
et cette rencontre entre une idéologie
qui se répand et qui est
laisse à penser que tout devrait être
public et une technologie qui met
d'entrée assez profondément dans notre
vie produit 3 effet je simplifie qui
peuvent être négatif enfin qu'ils sont
en train de devenir négatif
le premier effet on vient de le voir
c'est la destruction de la vie privée le
deuxième effet on voit aussi tous les
jours c'est ce que nous avons appelé
dans un livre que je viens d'écrire le
tribunal du buzz avec les réseaux
sociaux se sont créés s'est créé un
immense prétoire à ciel ouvert dans
lequel il n'y a pas de procédure
contradictoire pas d'avocat même pas dix
piges et dans lequel des réputations
sont faites et défaites sur la base
d'informations qui ne sont pas
nécessairement vrai et qui de surcroît
vous poursuivront toute votre vie
puisque dans le monde numérique n'y a
pas de droit à l'oubli et le troisième
élément négatif de cette transparence
à côté de la destruction de la vie
privée de la destruction de la
présomption d'innocence on abolit le
hasard il ya des techniques de calcul
qui vont nous dire ce que nous devons
consommer ce que nous tous nous engager
à partir de l'analyse de nos préférences
passé on va nous expliquer ce que nous
devons faire dans l'avenir
pour moi le meilleur exemple de cette
abolition du hasard c'est les sites de
rencontre l' inverse de l'amour
le personnage de l'un des personnages
principaux de la recherche du temps
perdu
swann dit à propos de la femme qu'il a
aimée tout ça pour une femme qui n'était
même pas mon genre l'amour c'est ça
c'est de rencontrer des gens qui ne sont
pas votre genre et d'être modifiée par
eux de les modifier et finalement de
s'entendre avec eux bien dans la
désormais nous nous rencontrerons que
des gens qui sont exactement notre genre
quelle tristesse voilà l'univers si je
le thrace je le définis à grands traits
l'univers dangereux que qu'organise sous
nos yeux
l'hyper transparence déterminé par une
forme d'idéologie et servi par une
certaine technologie une révolution
technologique
je voudrais dire tout de suite que en
quand j'expose ça un peu caricatural
mans je pense que la révolution
technologique est fantastique
la révolution numérique je pense qu elle
produit beaucoup plus de bien être
qu'elle ne produise danger mais
simplement si on veut en bénéficier
pleinement
il faut soit consciente sa face sombre
et qu'on la maîtrise c'est exactement ce
qui s'est produit à chaque fois qu'il ya
eu un grand progrès technique
pensez à la médecine la médecine nous a
fait avancer dans des proportions
considérables et en même temps elle
présentait des dangers par exemple
l'eugénisme et bien on a mis un terme à
ces dangers à travers les lois
bioéthiques penser à l'énergie les
énergies
modernes ont transformé radicalement
notre vie mais on sait aussi maintenant
par exemple à travers la question du
réchauffement climatique que les progrès
dans l'énergie détruire la planète et
donc on s'est mis à contrôler les
progrès de cette énergie à travers
l'écologie eh bien c'est exactement ça
qu'il faut faire en matière de numérique
de digital il faut en quelque sorte une
forme d'écologie du numérique
il faut qu'on se débrouille pour que le
numérique soit soluble dans la
civilisation telle que nous l'avons
mérité au lieu que nous dit seuls vion
cette civilisation dans le numérique et
comment est ce qu'on arrive à ça on
arrive par l'anp je vais à grands traits
parce que je vais vite mais on arrive
par trois voix principalement la
première c'est d'abord d'en débattre
aucun des contrôles que j'évoquais en
matière de médecine d'environnement de
se sont produits les citoyennes et les
citoyens n'ont repris le contrôle de ces
progrès technique que parce qu'ils ont
commencé à discuter ensemble des dangers
que ça représentait et donc il faut qu'
il ya un débat citoyen il faut qu'on
soit conscient du sujet du numérique on
voit évidemment et qu'on soutienne son
progrès mais qu'on soit conscient de ses
effets négatifs pour qu'on puisse
réfléchir à des solutions
la deuxième solution j'aurais dû
commencer par là c'est la première en
fait c'est l'éducation
il faut que dans les écoles dans les
collèges dans les lycées on apprenne à
nos enfants
la plupart d'entre vous n'ont pas encore
d'enfant mais à vos enfants futurs et à
mes petits enfants
il faut qu'on apprenne à la caq qu'il
compile faut qu'ils comprennent
l'usagé de ces technologies parce que
l'essentiel des problèmes de ces
technologies vient de leur usage
davantage que des technologies elle même
de ce qu'on fait de ce compost sur les
réseaux de la façon dont on traite
autrui dans les réseaux etc etc
donc c'est le deuxième élément est le
troisième élément très important à
panthéon assas
c'est la loi le droit les règles pas
forcément le droit dans le dur tel qu'il
existait dans la société d'avant mais ce
que les américains appellent des soft
blues
ddd code de bonne conduite notamment
avec ceux qui les entreprises qui
bénéficient principalement de la
révolution numérique qui sont au coeur
des problèmes de réseau ou d'intrusion
dans la vie privée que j'ai voté je sais
pas il n'est pas évident qu'on arrive à
faire tout ça il ya toute une quand on
voit les obstacles qui se dressent sur
notre route ils sont nombreux par
exemple nous n'avons pas du tout la même
conception que les américains en cette
matière et les technologies ne
connaissent pas les frontières
on a pas que les mêmes les mêmes visions
que les américains parce que pour le
faire là encore de manière schématique
nous on considère que nous sommes nous
données personnelles en europe les
données personnelles c'est un droit de
la personne aux etats unis ils
considèrent qu'ils ont les données
personnelles
les données personnelles c'est un droit
de la propriété
les données personnelles pour eux c'est
comme un appartement une voiture ça peut
se vendre
ça peut se louer ça se régule
principalement par le marché nous on
considère que
les données personnelles c'est comme un
membre de notre corps on n'a pas toutes
latitudes on n'a pas toute souveraineté
sur ses données personnelles et elles
relèvent du droit qui nous dépasse donc
vous voyez que arrivé à se mettre
d'accord avec les états unis aujourd'hui
avec la chine demain sur la manière dont
on traite ces données ce n'est pas
évident mais comme je suis un optimiste
impénitent et par ailleurs que la
lecture de l'histoire renforts cet
optimisme je me dis que la révolution
numérique n'a qu'une quinzaine d'années
en fait quinzaine d'années c'est
beaucoup à l'échelle de nos existences
année rien n'allait celle de l'histoire
de l'humanité et donc progressivement la
confiance viendra à l'humanité de la
nécessité de se contrôler et obstacles
qui nous paraissent infranchissable
aujourd'hui seront franchies voilà voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire très heureux
de le dire devant vous d'abord parce que
vous êtes jeune et que donc l'avenir
c'est vous et puis parce que en tout cas
pour l'essentiel d'entre vous vous êtes
juriste et que c'est principalement par
le droit le sait le socle du roi qui
permettra de limiter les effets négatifs
de cette de cette révolution
voilà donc je m'arrête là et je voudrais
pour conclure vous quitter sur une
citation d'un philosophe qui s'appelle
hans jonas la philosophe allemand qui a
écrit au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale et des horreurs qu'elle avait
créé et qui est considéré comme l'un des
premiers penseurs de l'écologie et il
avait reformuler l'impératif catégorique
dont on se souvient tous par nos études
de terminale et il l'avait formulé ainsi
agi de façon que les effets de ton
action soit compatible avec la
permanence d'une vie authentiquement
humaine sur terre est basse et
l'impératif que nous devons tous
comprendre à notre charge notamment en
matière numérique contrôler les effets
de cette révolution pour que nous
continuons d'avoir une vie
authentiquement humaine sur terre c'est
à dire très précisément l'héritage que
nous avons reçues merci à vous
[Applaudissements]